okay this is super interesting i must
have gotten 10 or 12 emails and tweets
from people saying david you have to
cover the discussion that took place
yesterday between joe rogan
and ben shapiro and um
i looked at it and it is super
interesting and i want to talk about it
right wing darling
ben shapiro was on joe rogan's program
yesterday
and there was a really interesting
discussion about
historical racism in the united states
systemic racism reasons for
unequal outcomes in the united states
today along racial lines
and it actually is a very
uh relevant conversation about systemic
racism and i have to tell you ben
shapiro actually does make some
important concessions here
although he always hides them in the
right wing
talking points that that he's very much
attached to
and he probably would have gotten away
with a lot more of it had joe rogan not
pushed back so let's just
jump right in and i'll comment as we go
i don't know that we need that much
introduction
is there middle ground d so
if we look at 1776 and we look at the
declaration of independence and we look
at america today in 2020
there clearly is some impact
in the echoes of slavery and then after
that jim crow there's clearly
some impact in these deeply impoverished
communities that don't seem to advance
yes so the to to to make the argument
about institutional racism
there's a couple ways you can read this
when people say systemic racism or
institutional racism
i usually ask them to be a little more
specific in what they mean because there
are a few ways you can read that one is
history has impact of course that's true
right that's true for everybody
it's true in your family history if you
have a grandfather who
went to who went to prison on a
particular charge that leads to poverty
for your parents which led to more
poverty for you right
people have histories those histories
are embedded in their life experiences
and that's true for societies as well
all of that is for sure true
then there's the question as to whether
the institutions today are racist
and that's not quite the same thing
right because history has consequences
is not the same thing as saying the
rules today are racist
because the rules today are not racist
actually the rules today are quite not
racist
so this part of the conversation is very
well illustrated by what i call a
monopoly
monopoly analogy where uh it's about the
what the rules are now versus the
historical impact so here's the monopoly
analogy which applies to
people like ben shapiro saying listen
we've fixed the rules
we've fixed the problem because the
rules now are no longer racist so
with monopoly everybody starts with the
same amount of money
and the same amount of property which is
zero at the beginning of the game
but imagine that three players hang
around and play monopoly for an hour and
they start buying up the properties and
driving up the rents and putting houses
and hotels on the properties and the
utilities are owned park place boardwalk
you guys all know monopoly
and then a fourth player comes in and
everybody's playing by the same rules
that fourth player gets the same
amount of money the fourth player is
allowed to buy any property that they
want the fourth player is bound to pay
rent
if they land on a square that is owned
by a different player
so the rules are exactly the same for
everybody they
are they are equitable rules but the
fact
that you were starting after a bunch of
the properties have been bought up
and the rents have been increased is a
very much
uh uh it's a it's a an analogy
to what we are talking about today in
terms of how we fix the law
when it comes to race and how we
properly dealt with
historical issues that are still
relevant today
so for example we now have hiring
non-discrimination laws you're not
allowed to
there's no lower minimum wage for black
or hispanic workers
legally there's no you're not allowed to
say we only hire white people here right
that that has been fixed so to speak but
you still have historic or redlining
and um uh uh disproportionately people
of color
living in neighborhoods that were
previously areas
where folks were pushed to when they
were not white and that relates to the
public transit system in a way that
makes it more difficult on average to
get to where
where the better jobs are so even if the
employer can no longer discriminate and
say we prefer not to hire black people
or hispanic people or whatever
you have all of this historical stuff
which is still very relevant
um so then the question becomes well
what if anything should we be doing
about it and then
joe rogan pushes back again so but
historically it's fairly recent
if you go from the civil rights movement
to 2020 we're really not talking about
that much time
it's about three generations 50 plus
years 60 years yeah i mean it's
50 plus right in the world of you know
in the fast span of human history it's
not a very small amount of time right
so clearly there's some impact of both
racism
and jim crow laws so that that's where
i'm saying there's a middle ground yeah
and
it's in den it is important for people
on my side of the conservatives to
acknowledge and recognize the importance
of history in people's living situations
now
and it's important for people on the
other side of the aisle to at the same
time not attribute every single thing
to history because right but people are
believing something like that
there's always like extremes on each
position
and the truth lies somewhere in the
middle yeah but i don't think that it
lies as far in
in the dead center of that as people i
think want it to so this is already an
important admission by ben shapiro he
says
there is a balance there's a balance
between historical impacts and personal
responsibility
it's not just about personal
responsibility now of course ben
says it's not 50 50. and that's where
the argument is well is it 80 percent
historical discrimination and 20
personal agency or is it 70 percent
personal in 30
history we would very much disagree but
it's an important concession that joe
rogan extracts
from ben shapiro here now let's skip
ahead a little bit and you're going to
see
that despite making the concession ben
jumps right back into
this is mostly just black people have to
decide for themselves that they're going
to improve their lives and fix the
situation so
despite the concession he still goes
back to that the
the way to fight against that is to make
good decisions
and so the you fight against the system
to make sure that the system has
rules that apply equally to everyone
right but you clearly see that there's a
big difference between people coming
over here willingly
and doing so in order to better their
lives versus someone
whose ancestors were dragged over here
to be sold as property
and then dealing with the repercussions
of that
being your family history and redline
laws
and all the other things that were put
in place to sort of keep them
in very specific areas which to this day
remain
crime-ridden gang-ridden deeply
impoverished communities well that's
true but the question is how much of
that is historic redlining and how much
of that is an 18 year old kid today
deciding to pep a gun and shoot somebody
but how much of that 18 year old kid
today
deciding to pick up a gun and shoot
somebody is based on him
growing up in this [ __ ] up environment
where that's what he models where
everything around him is crime and
gangs and you imitate your atmosphere
which what all humans do right but the
answer is there's only one way to break
that chain
what what way is that that way is to not
pick up a gun and shoot somebody i think
meaning
a simplistic way of looking at it if
you're on the outside of that community
and you're not one of those 18 year old
kids that grows up with the incredible
influence of all the people around him
and that's all you see
and that's all you know well but the
problem is the only way that's going to
be
the thing that your kid doesn't know is
for you not to do it at some point
personal agency has to come in some
it does because the expectation
education and and teaching them
about personal agency and and letting
them
understand that there's a way out of
this and that the path that they see
being replicated over and over again by
these people that wind up dying young
that wind up going to jail
that there are other options so ben is
saying now
the only way out is personal agency each
individual
has to just fix the situation for
themselves and say
i am going to change stuff now one of
the reasons why
uh ben is successful is that
he says things that on a superficial
practical level
sound so obvious and that's where he
gets this reputation if he just tells it
like it is
you know facts don't care about your
feelings on a very practical level
yes if an individual takes a different
action
then they improve their situation the
problem
is that if you fall for that idea it
pushes us to having to say the country
no longer has any responsibility when
ben shapiro says
the only way out is personal agency it
means the country as a whole
all of us can essentially wash our hands
of history and say
just personal agency they just need to
fix it themselves
but here as joe rogan points out we have
to
enable people to do that we have to set
people up
to do that there's a lot of kids that
never get that other information or if
they get it
they get little blips of it but the vast
majority of the information the vast
majority of the influence they get is
terrible well
i totally agree with this and this is
why i think the worst thing that you can
say to a kid
is you're born behind the eight ball and
no matter what you do you're not gonna
succeed
right that's literally the worst thing
you can say to a kid what you should be
saying is look at how your grandfather
was born behind the eightfall and look
how hard he had to work
in order to get ahead and look at all
the options that's true though but if
your grandfather
wasn't ahead didn't get ahead if your
grandfather
was in and out of jail if your father
was in and out of jail everyone around
you is like that
if there's literally no influence that's
positive in your life
the idea of saying to a kid like that
hey don't pick up a gun and shoot
somebody
it's way that's way too simplistic a
version
of of their future in my mind
i don't see an alternative solution so
joe rogan rightly points out
ben's idea of pointing to grandpa or dad
and saying there is another path look at
what grandpa did look at what dad did
that only works when grandpa or dad are
actually examples of that and that's the
problem if grandpa or dad were already
examples that you want to live up to
we wouldn't have the problem we have on
our hands sometimes grandpa and dad
aren't the right examples
and that is exactly what joe rogan is
pointing out and ben says well i just
don't see an alternative solution
and of course there are endless
alternative solutions
now this is typically where folks like
ben and others will say
reparations won't fix this and that's
often a straw man
i'm not even thinking of reparations and
it is actually true
that whether you can make a moral case
for handing
cash to people is not at issue
because just handing cash to people
won't actually fix the issues joe rogan
is talking about here we need to go
further than
are the rules racist on paper today
and ben is right that on paper the rules
are mostly not racist today but that's a
way to wash our hands of the problem to
say we fix the rules
and they're now fine and that's it well
that runs into the monopoly paradox that
i outlined
earlier so now we actually need to do
the tough work of figuring out
what's the right way to go forward
now that we fix the rules on paper
fixing the rules on paper is step one
right it's not the solution and there's
the historical piece that joe rogan
points out now just one more brief
element here
the topic of colin kaepernick kneeling
came up
in sort of a weird way let's just take a
look at it and i have a few thoughts
about it
like when people say it's hard to make
money in this country there
are a lot of people making money a lot
of different ways yes in this country
and i mean
i forgot to say colin kaepernick has
made millions of dollars kneeling for
the national anthem it feels like and
calling america racist while cashing the
check this is a great damned country
well we're now we're getting into the
weeds
i just wanted to talk about girls
ripping dudes off i know you did but we
can go back there man
that's okay but the colin kaepernick
thing
all right don't you think that
at least some good has come out of
him doing that where it sort of
raised awareness for police brutality
just let just put it to the forefront
let people
like let people understand that this is
a problem
no no no no because i think that he made
a serious error which is that the most
positive movements in american social
history
have been ones that don't kneel for the
flag but say in the name of the flag you
should do x
right so martin luther king said in the
name of the flag civil rights are
necessary
so the problem with ben's idea that
instead of kneeling
you say in the name of the flag we
should do x or y
you know he gives us this nice martin
luther king example which sounds great
and of course ben is smart
by giving that example as the right
winger oh he's talking about martin
luther king that's great that he did the
right thing
but how many people uh have said in the
name of the flag
we should shut up and support our troops
in fighting this war
2003 that was happening with the iraq
war do the patriotic thing
in the name of the flag support the
troops in their mission in iraq
which we went into ridiculously because
saudi arabians attacked us on 911 what
that didn't make sense
hey don't kneel just in the name of the
flag
ask for support well that's what people
did when it came to the iraq war
and that's a very very dangerous
direction to go in so this is
interesting on a few different
a few different levels um you can check
out the the entire exchange which is
about 20 minutes you know we played four
or five
of the minutes here um i i do think that
it is um a step forward in a sense
that we got the admission from ben
shapiro that there is a balance
between personal responsibility and the
historical realities
i would vehemently disagree with him
about where the balance likely is
but a very interesting conversation and
a relevant one
and interestingly a lot of dislikes for
this appearance by ben shapiro but i
don't know
if the dislikes were from people who
disagree with ben shapiro
or from people who weren't pleased with
joe rogan's position as many of you may
know
whenever i go on joe rogan's program
brutal
brutal dislikes and my instinct
is it's people saying they don't like my
views
but i don't know if that's necessarily
where the dislikes came from
for this ben shapiro discussion with joe
rogan i just don't know
and it would be interesting uh to think
about let's take a quick break
we have so much more to discuss coming
up
one of our sponsors today is a snack
brand
called just the cheese and they are
giving our audience
20 off all of their products just the
cheese is a snack bar
made with only one ingredient 100
percent
all natural wisconsin cheese it is
crunchy
it is a baked snack created to mimic the
cheese that
bakes off into the pan and gets crunchy
when you make a grilled cheese sandwich
it's absolutely delicious and because
every bite
is just cheese that's all it is it's
packed with calcium
and protein has virtually no carbs
no sugar completely gluten free
perfect if you're looking for a low carb
snack
on the go available in three varieties
aged cheddar grilled cheese
and jalapeno my favorite a little bit of
a kick you know i love a kick
just the cheese is manufactured by a
family-owned cheese company in the heart
of wisconsin it's
simple tasty crunchy delicious
again it's called just the cheese you
can find their amazon
page by going to davidpakman.com slash
cheese and you can get 20 percent off by
using
code 20 pacman at checkout
that's davidpakman.com cheese and use
the code
two zero p a k m a n for twenty percent
off